I mean I was a pathologically
competitive person in my teens I mean
actually from childhood I think it's
only like my second or third European
Poker Tour event so I'm not comfortable
this is much higher Stakes than I'm used
to playing really it's a 5 000 Euro
buy-in fairly inexperienced at it long
story short I end up winning the whole
thing for 1.25 million euros bloody hell
what you're about to hear is an
interview between me and Liv bori now
Liv is a World Series of Poker and
European Poker Tour Champion now live
story is super interesting because she
actually has a degree in astrophysics
and she combined her science background
and passion for games to get into the
world of Poker and to win all of these
championships I remember sort of the end
of my third year hanging out with a
bunch of PhD students and they didn't
seem like they were having a
particularly good time so decided to
take a gap here at the end of my
graduation which was coincided right
around when I went on this game show
that introduced me to Poker I went to a
local Card Club in London I had five ten
I think literally a tenor on me or maybe
15 quid and I end up winning the whole
thing in the conversation we talk about
a whole bunch of things and by the end
of the episode you'll learned firstly
about Liv's inspirational story around
how she took risks and followed her
hunch and ended up building a life that
she could have never imagined we talk a
little bit about effective altruism and
how we can become better philanthropists
and have more of an impact by using
logic and reason to figure out the most
high expected value thing that we can do
to help solve the world's most pressing
problems and we talk about the dangers
of social media as it relates to
artificial intelligence and why AI is
the most high-stakes creation by humans
to date and what the implications are
for our future part of the problem with
social media is it reduces the richness
and complexity of The Human Experience
down to like these very narrow metrics
by definition it's inherently
dehumanizing it's like we're trapped in
this an attention game but game is the
nice way of calling it in reality it's
an attention War
at the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun Liv
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast thank you for having me um you
seem to be doing lots and lots of things
like former professional poker player
you've got like television broadcasting
and presenting YouTube channel and
podcast uh you're associated with the
effective altruism community and I was
really struggling to figure out what is
it that you're doing right now like how
would you describe what you do if
someone asks you at like a party for
example yeah good question
um well my main focus right now is
getting a podcast off the ground
and that's going to be on the sort of
the topic of
how do we find more healthy competition
in the world and what is people's
relationship with with competition as
this sort of way of interacting with one
another because it seems like you know
competition is a core part not only of
human nature but of nature itself
um but
from the more I look into it it seems
like competition is getting a little
it's going in the unhealthy Direction
um certainly in things like
uh fast developing Technologies where
there's so much pressure you know so
many short-term incentives on companies
you know like the ai ai for example all
these companies are under so much
pressure to be the first one to develop
the next thing that
it's hard for them to also do you know
focus on safety as much as perhaps they
should be
um same goes with like the competitive
forces that are driving deforestation
you know people are just trying to
survive you know get by and they see
that their neighbors are cutting down a
bit of rain for us well I'm going to do
it too right yeah
um so that's sort of my current area of
obsession yep and I'm trying to raise
awareness of the the mechanisms that
seem to be driving this stuff through my
YouTube channel
um I've been working on this series
called molok
um which we can talk about a bit more
and then yeah the podcast and then also
give talks regularly on poker thinking
um really whatever people want to hear
about nice uh so yeah I don't know how
you put that yeah it's hard to turn that
into like a noun or something I feel
like when I was a doctor it was very
easy to be like that's the thing but now
it's like some combination of YouTube
videos podcasts writing like how like
yeah I guess influencer yeah why does
that that word comes with such baggage
yeah influencer Creator crater yeah
something like that yeah so you're uh so
so you're on this game show as the
professor one of the five personalities
are you like 22 20-ish 31 21 at this
point so what happened on the game show
oh man uh so the way it worked was I
think we filmed
six it was six or seven episodes and
each episode we would play a sit and go
inside so it didn't go as where so
there'd be the five of us playing plus a
qualifier each week
um this this whole show was sponsored by
an online poker company
you know it was a marketing thing for
them and so you know it was trying to
get people to go oh watch the show play
online see if you could qualify for the
next episode or whatever
um and so we would all play and it
basically a sit and go is is like a mini
tournament where
you'll start with an equal number of
chips and if you lose all your chips
you're out and it's a last last person
standing type thing and so based on the
results of each of those we would
accumulate points which would go forward
into the final where it would be just
the five of us playing for the hundred
thousand pounds which again wanna take
all
pretty aggressive yeah um especially for
a bunch of beginners where none of us
really knew what we were doing
um and so
the the first few episodes of the show
went very well for me like I clearly had
you know I got the game and I loved the
game from the outset and the funny thing
is during the filming I went to a local
Card Club in London uh called the gut
shot
and they had this Infamous tournament
called the five pound rebuy where it was
just you know you could re-buy it for
the first hour for five five quid but I
didn't know that it was a rebuy and you
know I was fairly broke yeah I feel like
five pounds one off yeah I bought ten I
had I had five ten I think literally a
tenor on me or maybe 15 quid but you
know that was like this was for drinks
and I've got my five pound entry
and so then I'm watching like people
literally going all in every hand just
like you know rebuy rebuy rebound I'm
like I can't I can't do this so somehow
I get through the rebuy period with my
one button
and I end up winning the whole thing
that like coming home at like five in
the morning with you know it was like
120 entrance and like I am a straight up
beginner yeah win this thing and I
remember going home to my boyfriend at
the time with this hat and full of cash
more cash I've ever seen like 800 800
quid and just like throwing it on him
we're like around my new career
um so that was a very interesting sort
of start to video yeah and that was
midway through filming for the TV show
yes so like are they training you on how
to play poker yeah so we had
um they they had three pros that would
come and like help us
um you know two of whom well uh it was
devil fish Dave devil fish Elliot
um who Sally's passed away now
um but he was the UK's most famous poker
player for a while certainly back then
Annie Duke who at the time was the most
successful female poker player now does
a lot of yeah she's written books about
like uh yeah yeah she's a very good
writer
um and Phil Hellmuth who is probably the
most famous poker player alive today oh
okay cool yeah so these guys are
coaching you they kind of how to play
poker yes so these were the three
coaches and
um
it was you know so now all of a sudden I
meet these I remember looking up sort of
what their what their lives are like and
I'm like wow these guys wait this is
even better than being a rock star these
guys get to travel the world they're
treated like rock stars they you know
they have all these adoring fans they're
having a great time but they get to play
this incredible game which frankly seems
a lot more fun than actually guitar so
that's where I first was like oh maybe
this could be my my new career uh and
certainly yeah it it it definitely came
it was definitely the most exciting
thing I did yeah thus far because I
guess for most people if you're just
kind of playing poker casually you
wouldn't then jump to thinking this
could be a career but I guess because
you're interacting with these three
people who've literally made
professional poker playing their career
right and then you win this competition
you're like hang on maybe there's
something in this like free easy money
or whatever what's what's going through
your mind no I mean exactly that yeah
yeah I was just like well I've clearly
got a gift for this yeah like I win this
tournament and I mean looking back on it
I must have just run we call it running
running like God where just the cards
are so on your side because to win any
tournament you need you can be the best
player in the world but if the cards are
not cooperating you just cannot win like
it's almost impossible and certainly in
the tournament that sort of fast paced
um so the cards must have just been
completely yeah I don't really remember
I remember I flopped four of a kind and
so on which is you know very unlikely
given you know I'm probably playing like
400 Hands Across the whole tournament
um what does it mean to flop a four of a
kind uh so I had you have
um let's see you have two sevens your as
your whole cards yep and then the Flop
comes out which is three cards oh okay
two of those seven the two other seven
okay which is extraordinarily unlikely
oh I can't remember the odds right now
but it's a good thing to flop a four of
kind oh it's incredible oh yeah yeah
very very very very good thing in an
incredibly rare we're talking like it's
I I embarrassingly can't remember the
the odds right now but it's like on the
order of like 1 in 36 000 or something
like that
um so had that in this yeah so that's
that's what I'm saying the cards but
absolutely on my side it was definitely
more luck than a skill thing yeah
clearly knowing what I know now but I
didn't know that and I was just like wow
I must be the best and then coupled with
I then win the first uh sit and go on
the show and I think I'll do one on the
second or the third one and
um
and I remember like the you know the
pros and the shows organizers but being
all excited like you're clearly the
favorite you're gonna win this you're
gonna win this like you're clearly very
good at this game you're the big
favorite and so I was just like dead
sure I was gonna win it
but I did not win it
um
because on the on the final uh the final
set and go you know the um we were
playing for the 100K
again I can't remember the exact hand
but
it was against this this other other
player Lee
um who was probably the second best
player actually
um he made a big bet on the river and I
had rivered a straight sorry what does
River mean the final card the fifth card
so the three come out on the Flop and
then the turn is the fourth and then the
river is the fifth and then you have
your two cards that we've got to make
out of those seven why is it called flop
turn River I don't know like okay cool
it's one of those things yeah so he's
betting on the final card yes we get to
the final card yeah just after this is
where you turn your hand over and he
bets big
and I've rivered a straight so five
cards in a row essentially
and I'm me I'm so excited I'm like I
raise
so that means I'm now committed to at
least double his his uh his bet yep
which would leave me behind with
basically nothing yep but as I say I
raise and then look back at the board
and I realize there's four diamonds out
there oh okay and I know that both my
cards were black yep so all it means is
if he just has one diamond yeah he's got
a flash he's got a Flash and he's
beating me and
you know people even pros make mistakes
like this sometimes they misread the
board and so on but you know what this
is what you train your Poker Face for
you just stay you know if you notice
something like that you just stay cool
yeah I did not do that I looked at the
board and went
[Laughter]
and I remember him looking at me and I'm
like and we're looking and he's looking
at the board and he's looking back at me
and a single tear starts because I know
this because I saw you know the footage
starts rolling down my face
and he's just like um
Flynn so he revises to put me all in and
I just
have a complete meltdown to start crying
I think I'd run away yeah run away from
the table the cameras follow like
classic like reality I'm like get the
camera out my face awful
um and then I bust shortly after
uh so that's how that's how that went so
it was a nice slap back down to earth
how does that feel to kind of have the
hundred hundred thousand pounds snatched
away it was awful because I was so sure
I was winning it and you know it was a
life-changing amount of money absolute
life-changing and like I and it was yeah
it was brutal because I think it was
probably sounds
weird thing to say but you know I'd had
a pretty Charmed Life I have I've had a
very Charmed Life I'm not you know uh
but this was the first real like
you're not always going to get your way
you know way I was so sure like oh yes
this is the next great you know good
thing that's going to happen to me and
like no yeah
um how long how long did it take you to
forgive yourself for that
no
I mean definitely lingered for a few
years
two years oh yeah what just like the
what ifs yeah just like the you know
like oh man my career would have been
I mean you just would it would have been
provided me with a bankroll yep from
from the outset but then again had I won
that
I would have carried you know because I
was essentially delusional right about
my skill level everything that up until
that point had deluded me you know
winning the first few sentences having
the producers tell me I'm the best
um clever by then because they want
drama for their show and I was probably
the most likely to be you know this
precocious overconfident 21 year old
girl most likely to cause drama you know
be the drama which was the case
um
but yeah if I had won that then I who
knows I probably wouldn't have studied
the game very hard
um
I have no yeah no idea I mean I just I
certainly wouldn't change anything yeah
because you know here we are absolutely
okay so you're you're 21 at this point
you're on your Gap here from University
and you've just nearly won 100 000
pounds on a poker show what happens next
so
I tell my parents that I want to make it
I'm putting physics on hold I'm not
going to apply for my masters just yet
uh I want to see if I can make a go at
this poker thing I stopped playing
regularly at that gut shot Card Club
um to you know fairly decent success
actually and start you know actually
learning the game and becoming a bit
better
um but my dad was just like this is
still not acceptable you need to get a
job like you can't just try and live off
this you need to you need to go into you
know
grow up essentially so uh I just apply I
can't remember you know through some
recruitment you know website for just
jobs in London that want physicists
um and one of the first ones that came
up like you know had a opportunity to
interview for was for a company called
advertising.com which was a subsidiary
of AOL and it was like early days Google
um search ads yep and I was essentially
it was my role was like data analysts to
figure out the optimal time to present
the ads
um using their they had some kind of
algorithm that would you I can't even
remember it frankly but so I got that
job and it was you know in clock and
well
and
I hated it so much so anyway I was never
a morning person and like it just felt I
was just felt like I was just going
through the motions every day like you
have to be there at 9am but then
if you walked in 901 people would be
looking and tutting at you and don't
forget like the people that were
actually really nice but I just
I just was getting by doing the bare
minimum just feeling like I didn't
believe in what I was doing
um but again glad for the experience
because you know it really showed me
what my purse what worked for my
personality and what didn't
um
but uh yeah so did that for about a year
and then
right around you know I was looking for
an opportunity to quit but poker wasn't
going enough it wasn't enough to replace
my salary but then one December I was
playing an online satellite tournament
so satellites are where you know usually
instead of winning money directly a
surprise you win an entry to a big
bigger tournament yeah
and it was a 300 online buy and I played
it and it was again a winner take haul
and I won it for this nineteen thousand
dollar package to go to Las Vegas oh
nice to go and play in the world world
Poker Tour this 15 000 buy-in so it's
like 15 plus 4K expenses nice and I won
it again at like six in the morning and
I had to go into work the next day
and also by that point I had used up all
of my holiday
on like traveling to go and like I
started doing poker reporting as well at
the same time because I was like just
like how do I get into this industry as
well maybe I can you know do media and
that sort of thing
um report on it meet people uh so I'd
use up all my holidays sort of
Moonlighting as this poker reporter uh
and I went to my boss and I was like
look uh I know I don't have any left but
I need to go to Vegas next week I just
won this I obviously will take unpaid
and he's like you can't no we need you
and I was like but this is worth you
know almost as much as my entire annual
salary yeah and this is my dream and
he's like well we need you and I was
like well I'm sorry I'm going so I quit
uh actually it wasn't I wasn't as
douchey as that I like he didn't
actually say they needed me but it was
just like for some reason they couldn't
give me the unpaid I mean I I totally
understand he was so understanding
um and he's like well I I totally
understand off you go so I went off to
Vegas I did not win but I met like all
the stars I saw Phil Hellmuth and Annie
again devil fish you know reconnected
with them and I was just and it's
cemented like okay this is why I want to
do I want to travel to these events yes
this is the funnest thing imaginable
um so yeah that and so then I quit and
that's when I started going sort of full
time okay so let's say someone's
listening to this and they're in the so
let's say they're 21 they've got a
degree and they could get a normal job
but they want to take a risk doing
something like a startup or start a
YouTube channel or a podcast or a poker
or something like that
what like I I get emails from people in
that kind of position quite a lot where
they're always like do I get the job or
do I go full time on the thing given
it's a bit of a risk or do I go like
full time on the job and sort of half
off the job and like kind of do the
thing on the side like what would you
advise kind of your younger self or
someone in that position given what you
know now
I forgot because
Corey is
usually like falling on the sort of the
Good Fortune outcomes so
you know if I ran the simulation of my
life again
it's very statistically unlikely that it
would end up this way right
so technically on paper the decisions I
made we probably you know I definitely
took this riskier decision each time and
it happened to work out but that doesn't
mean to say that that is actually the
correct that was the correct decision at
the time right
so it really depends
um
yeah it's it's so situationally
dependent I wouldn't want to say like to
say oh yeah always take them like the
people who say no always go with your go
with your heart take the risk
it's it's it's it's a nice guiding
principle but it shouldn't be a hard and
fast rule
similarly no stick with what you know do
the same thing
can be a good guiding principle but you
shouldn't stick stick to it hard and
fast so I think it somewhat depends on
your personality a bit you know like
there is we all sort of fall somewhere
on the spectrum of risk tolerance
and I think the best thing you can do is
like get to know yourself as much as
possible
um you know some people like like I
think a lot of poker players have in
common is they would much rather Gamble
and lose than to have never had the
opportunity to gamble in the first place
you know like the best outcome is to
gamble and win yep the second best
outcome is to gamble and lose and the
third the worst outcome is to never have
any action in the first place like
that's a sort of common theme amongst uh
this breed of people so if you fall into
that category then you're the sort of
you know you're more likely to you know
you take the risk a lot of the time you
lose but you can sort of stomach it
right you you it just works for you but
that's fairly rare most people have like
a large loss aversion
um and that's there's nothing wrong with
that in fact there's probably a
healthier way of existing
um so if you're someone who's going to
that experience more sort of suffering
from having you know taking a risky
decision that then doesn't work out
that should come into your Calculus
um and again if there's no right or
wrong answer it's just really it is very
subjective yeah and situationally
dependent yeah yeah I guess it's almost
um you know Jeff Bezos talks about
regret minimization like right you know
right try and project yourself forward
into the future and figure out which of
these am I more likely to regret yes
kind of regardless of the outcome
um
for me I find that that generally leans
towards I mean you know in my 20s
generally taking the risk is reasonable
but then I also have a financial safety
net and a family who can support me if
needed and all of this other kind of
stuff feeds into that right and then
people sometimes look at myself oh but
you took a risk and I'm like yeah but it
wasn't really a risk because it's like
you know if things don't work out I'm
not gonna starve I just get a job as a
doctor like the the we all have
different degrees of backup app
absolutely and I mean that's actually
one of the biggest forms of like innate
privilege is do you have parents at home
that if it all goes tits up will take
you in and let you stay there yeah like
I was very lucky that I had that as this
safety net where I was like I feel the
confidence to go out and do that a lot
of people don't have that and so they
don't have the luxury of taking these
big you know these these big gambles
because if like it doesn't work out they
might literally end up on the streets
and it's
um it sucks but that's you know there's
that disparity there like you know your
parents is one of the like biggest
things you can't control
and
you get to make it influences the course
of your life so much so yeah it it it's
it's interesting though like you know
now having gotten to know you know a lot
of tech leaders or just really really
successful people in you know in very
sort of competitive Industries like they
are you know the biggest sort of thing
they have in common is that they are
extremely comfortable with very
audacious risks
and you know so there's a selection
effect going on there but at the same
time these are by definition the
outliers yeah and and so we can't over
that you know just because that's what
happened to them that doesn't mean
you're statistically likely to happen to
you no exactly um so it's it's it's it's
so difficult so I think that yeah the
main thing to do is just like get get to
know yourself and that's why like
actually poker is such a good
um
it's it's probably the best game
in terms of to learn in terms of
learning how to make high-stakes
decisions for your life because it's
it's it's so messy and there's so many
different sort of types of skills you
need to hone from the like analytical
statistical
um Game Theory stuff to you know the
more sort of artistic fuzzy things like
people reading psychology
um being aware of your own emotions and
emotional control and that kind of thing
and then on top of that you've got you
know because I'm like a game of chess
where it's sort of it's complete
information
um there's no sort of hidden things
aside of what's going on in the person's
mind you know what's up whereas poker
the cards are randomly shuffled between
every hand right and you can be the best
player in the world and if the cards
aren't cooperating You're Gonna Lose and
vice versa you can be the worst player
in the world and if cards are on your
side you're when and
and so this and as you know this this
messiness especially with the luck
factor is so true of life and the true
the the the the the real skill comes in
identifying when your results are uh you
know if you have a string of success is
it down to your good decision making or
is it down to Good Fortune or maybe a
bit of both and if so what's the mix of
those and that's the hard thing yeah to
figure out both in poker and in life but
I want to just make a very clear caveat
right now I am not I do not recommend
anybody go out and try and become a
professional poker player now oh okay I
was gonna ask you this like let's say
someone's listening to this and they're
like side hustle is a poker player
sounds better than side hustle as a
part-time model like what why would you
not recommend it so the game and I mean
in short
it's because of
Ai and what computation essentially
um the game you know when I learned in
2005 no one really knew how poker worked
it was you know the best players in the
world like uh particularly like someone
like Phil uh who was on the show
um Doyle Branson those guys they what
made them so great is that they have had
and still have
these incredible intuitions about human
behavior you know they have these Street
smarts that they've gained from just
years and years and years of sitting at
the poker table and just seeing the full
gamut of human behavior and just having
so much experience they know how to
hustle and out maneuver people yeah
and that was sufficient to be a great
poker player and I had a bit of the sort
of statistical side but I also like
honed a lot of those skills as well but
then around sort of 2010 2011
Game Theory started becoming more of a
field of study in poker uh and
particularly uh analysis software
started emerging because you know with
online poker for the first time now all
your hand histories were digitized and
so you could save them so you had all
this data uh from which you could learn
from and then you know software
developed it where you could just
basically upload your hand histories and
it would show you oh okay in these sort
of positions you're you're losing money
here yeah you need to work on your your
small blind game Etc
so for those who are willing to like
take the analytical route now there was
this there was all this low-hanging
fruit of information you could use
and
the so there was all that that was
happening making it much more of a more
of a science instead of it before it was
an art and it started shifting more
towards the science and then on top of
that there's this so technically there's
a theoretical maximum of perfect play
that exists in poker it's called Game
Theory optimal
um and if you get two Game Theory
optimal players you know if let's say
we're both perfect GTO players uh and we
play against each other then we will
we're in what's called a Nash
equilibrium where what that means is
there is no single strategy that either
one of us can take to exploit the other
one's mistakes so we're essentially
breaking even against each other for
play over infinity like we you know one
might get luckier than the other of us
yeah you know an hour or so but if we
play to Infinity we would break it so
it's like if two computers play against
each other in chess
they will almost always draw uh yeah if
they're too equally matched once yes
um and I think chess has Nash
equilibrium as well yeah
um but certainly in poker that's the
case so what that means is that there's
actually a theoretical ceiling of
perfect play yep and back in you know
2005 or whatever
the best players in the world are down
here you know the medium ones were down
there and the beginners were on the
floor
but now because of the ceiling everyone
has shifted yep up to here and not only
has everyone shifted so much closer but
the gap between beginners and the pros
has shrunk
because this information that was
previously sort of like proprietary
information in everyone's heads has been
democratized through these through these
analysis softwares
um they're called simulators there's
this one called Pius solver that was you
know certainly the one everyone used
back when I was you know still playing
pro
um where you'd like input a scenario and
it would play
millions or billions of fictitious hands
against itself to find these
mathematically Optimal Solutions and
then your job is basically just to
memorize what the like appropriate
frequencies are of bluffing versus
um playing passively or whatever and so
it changed again like it was less of it
made the game in many ways sort of less
dynamic because
it turned it more into chess it was more
about like
figure you know choosing a position and
like memorizing the optimals plays as
opposed to just sort of like thinking on
your feet yeah um so that's why it's I
would not recommend anyone try and make
a living from it now
um a because everyone's so much closer
it's easier to get very good fast so you
should go and learn I highly recommend
people go and learn because you can
learn so much about yourself and you
know all the skills that it will give
you that apply to life but I wouldn't
recommend it as a source of income
um and especially not now that AI uh
because in 2017 we had the first
superhuman poker AI uh
and at the time that was uh it like ran
off a supercomputer it was very slow and
clunky
um but you know Moore's Law and all that
now you could have it on an app that
works almost I don't know if it's
completely in real time but it's close
to real time okay
um and that's for like the very very
best but you can have a very very
proficient one running
um so why does that mean that you
shouldn't uh well
the online poker
and at least in its classical form Texas
Holdem I wouldn't recommend playing high
stakes online poker anymore because if
if the other person's using an AI like
the incentives are just so strong yeah
and you know the same reason that people
don't play chess for lots of money
online yeah because you had enough
incentive there's gonna be cheating it
doesn't mean everyone's cheating but it
you can't be sure
um so but that said maybe and actually
live poker is booming so you know in
person poker is seeing a bit of a
Resurgence maybe because you know people
still want that action they want to play
for money yep so you want to you just
want to be able to see the person and
see that they're not on a phone yeah
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from this episode to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly huel now heal is great
because I've been a customer of Hill for
the last six years and also we've got an
interview with Julian Hearn who is the
founder of heal on this podcast so you
can check that out it'll be on the
YouTube channel and on the Spotify page
and that was a fantastic master class in
entrepreneurship but anyway we're
talking about heal because heel is a
fantastically complete meal so if you're
like me and you have a fairly busy life
and you don't necessarily make the time
to shop and cook and prep and wash up
like a healthy meal at home which is
obviously ideal then the nice thing
about heel is that it's a great
alternative to an unhealthy cereal or an
unhealthy takeaway meal for example I
particularly like the heel black edition
because this is high protein and lower
carb so for 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein and so this is
absolutely fantastic for workout days
where I'm trying to get my 160 180 grams
of protein in and it's also great
because the high protein helps me stay
full for a lot longer take my two scoops
of the Black Edition powder I like the
banana Edition and The Salted Caramel
Edition I'll mix it up in my NutriBullet
blender thing with water and maybe a
little bit of milk sometimes and then
I'll just sip on that while I'm working
at my desk and that will get me the
appropriate level of protein that I need
it'll get me a decent chunk of
carbohydrates and fibers and fat and
also 26 different vitamins and minerals
which are generally very good for the
body it's also very reasonably priced
like if you work it out it comes out to
one pound 68 per meal ish which is about
400 calories and that's way cheaper than
an alternative would be if you were
ordering takeout for example so if that
sounds up your street and you would like
a nutritionally complete and affordable
and healthy option for some of your
meals then head over to heel.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt and also a
free shaker bottle thing with your first
order I still use my t-shirt it's great
it's nice elasticy it fits reasonably
well it makes me look kind of hinged so
you can check that out heel.com forward
slash deep dive so thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212 now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can grow
and it's completely tax-free for the
rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your ice allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward the app
also lets you Auto invest which is a
great thing because then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode it strikes me that that poker
would be a good game to develop the
skill of uh resilience because if you
know you're playing well and then
something you know the cards just don't
go your way yes it would be easy in that
context like in real life to beat
yourself up and kind of go into a spiral
about this but I guess as a professional
poker player you have to just get over
it yes exactly um and it
took me and I mean
it struggled with that frankly to the
end of my career you know if I went on a
period of not winning much a downswing
as we call it
it would because I guess I almost always
had such high expectations of myself and
especially as my career sort of started
off so spectacularly
it
it just I never some some people are
better than others that are not getting
bogged down by the downswings but I it
always got me and that was my weakness
frankly
um
but either way it's definitely it still
definitely taught me a lot of resilience
I'm more resilient now than I would have
been without it for sure
what were the some strategies that you
used to sort of somewhat cope with the
downswings
and probably the most useful one is just
sort of doing the perspective game you
know just to go okay well so the last
three months have been terrible I've
lost this much I've not you know my I'm
slipping down the because this thing
came out which was like a sort of point
system of recent Tournament results
called the global poker index so it was
a way to try and like rank players even
though it was a terrible actual metric
yep you know who's all it shows is like
who's been playing a lot recently in
caching but if you didn't if you didn't
play much and you'd drop down the
rankings but nonetheless my silly brain
that loves to optimize for rankings as I
mentioned you know since kids looking am
I number one in the exams I was obsessed
with this and I
would yeah so I have a period of three
or four months with no results ah to
start feeling it and so the thing that
would be helpful would just sort of do
you know zoom out okay so the last three
months of [__] but let's look at the
last year okay it wasn't that good okay
but three years ago I won that big one
there and that was like
still above expectation and then prior
to that and prior to that and generally
speaking just there will be a radius of
sort of time that you can you could go
back to where things are actually
clearly on the positive
so just choose that because it's up to
you which perspective you choose that's
that's what you can control you can't
necessarily control what life does but
you can control the the time frame with
which you want to compare it of how it's
going you know where the trend line you
know is it is it doing this overall over
a 10-year period or is it doing this
okay but let's look at 20 years or
whatever so that's frankly the most
useful one and it's also you know the
longer the time period the more
meaningful the data right especially in
poker you know the bigger the sample
size then the more relevant it is yeah
so that that's the main one
um
and then the other thing as well when
you're especially when you're dealing
with any kind of
any kind of sort of decision-making
process process that has luck involved
is
is to
before you even sort of stop playing
okay I'll just bring it back to the
poker as the analogy you know
in between playing whether it's cash
games or tournaments in between the
actual action you need to be studying on
developing a good sort of thinking
process when you when you place you know
you do need to go and do your homework
and what I found helpful was coming up
with sort of
literally like a step-by-step process
that I would follow during hand where
you know which I know in a vacuum is the
optimal way of of thinking through a
problem and I'd work with a lot with
like my partner Igor who's much better
player than me and other Pros you know
what's what is their step-by-step
process okay I'm going to try and
emulate this and work out what works for
me and then at the end of a tournament I
don't look back and see you know how
much I want or not I look back and to
see how closely I adhered to that
process that I know is the optimal
process for me
so basically just being process focused
as opposed to results based
um and that's again that's what I that
became the new metric to measure Myself
by and that was a much healthier way of
approaching it and it again built that
resilience and so on now if I was
spending a lot of time not following my
process then technically I should be
annoyed at myself
um but interestingly I never yeah
would never get that annoyed with myself
I would not feel as bad about that as I
would for example if I was just looking
at the results yeah okay so you've got
your sponsorship deal you're flying
around these tournaments you've won the
women's European Championship
um just on that note
but men players versus women players is
there a
difference Advantage different styles of
thinking like in sports clearly there's
like you know that's why we have men's
women's leagues like what what is it
like in poker yeah
um it's such a
flip-flop on this too yeah on this topic
because
technically you know there is there's no
reason to have women's only tournaments
it's not a physical game
um it's not you know there's no body
weight or height or strength advantage
but for some reason
the ratios certainly on like the high
stakes Circuit of males to females are
incredibly imbalanced we're talking like
97 to three wow okay it's about as
Extreme as it gets
and the reason why female you know women
only tournaments
continue to be popular seems to be that
you know there's
women who'll come out and play those
that wouldn't play necessarily in an
open tournament now I'm very
in an Ideal World I don't I I can see
Arguments for both sides basically in an
Ideal World we don't need those because
it's like saying you know it's like oh
we need our own special event because we
can't compete with the boys and I hate
that that's a sort of narrative that can
be concluded from that yeah but at the
same time there's obviously some reason
going on why the ratios are so uh
imbalanced
and you know this is now you know the
reasons behind this is a big point of
contention
um
from you know from my experience it's a
it's so it's you know the the arguments
are like oh it's all because of sexism
and you know women are treated badly or
it's it's just because women are not
interested and they don't find the game
as fun as as men certainly not at high
stakes
and the real answer is it's both it's a
bit it's a mixture of both
um certainly there's been plenty of
sexism I've been I've experienced plenty
of sexism throughout my you know
throughout my career
but it's also very true that poker as a
game typically correlates more with what
you would classically call like more
like masculine type personality traits
so
uh things instead of people you know
especially as the games become more and
more analytical
um it's it you have to be willing to
just like go down the rabbit hole and
like just narrow focus on this one thing
um which tends to correlate more with
masculine traits but perhaps a more
notable thing it's a it's it's so
it is so much a game that requires a
huge tolerance for risk which like I
mean just go look at a children's
playground
the girls will be typically you know
playing nicer games with each other the
boys will be up a tree fighting you know
jumping off high things yeah now some
girls do that too I would happen to be
one of those girls that love that kind
of stuff but again this is all averages
but on average
that tends to be more of a you know
higher risk tolerance correlates more
with males and females
um and then the other thing as well is
it's an incredibly Cut Throat
competitive game like you have to be
you have to be a little bit Psychopathic
sometimes to be a really good poker
player but all because you know if you
you're looking for the weakness in your
opponent right your opponent wants you
know it's their money that they want and
you are trying to take it from them
and again that typically correlates that
that like yeah I'm gonna beat you I'm
gonna look for your weakness and take
you
get into your head and mess with you
don't get me wrong plenty of women can
be very good at that and can do that but
it tends to that tends to correlate more
with males so that's why I you know it
is the question is how much of it is due
to the like the innate traits the the
the the nature versus the nurture of
like the game has not always been the
most you know welcoming place for women
um
probably back in the day it was almost
entirely the the nurture reasons
um you know like the classic imagery of
Po it was like a boys club thing
sometimes women literally weren't
allowed in you know poker rooms so
clearly like that was a whole nurture
thing going on yeah these days you know
I I have been a beneficiary myself of
all the sort of affirmative action
trying to get more women in had I been a
guy there's no way I would have had all
the sponsorship deals I've had
so it's been a real double-edged sword
in the like I've clearly benefited
massively from it and there has been so
many great initiatives to get more women
into the game but we're still like and
the ratios have improved I don't like
much better than they used to be but
anyone who thinks it's going to get to
50 50 is absolutely delusional because
it's just certainly maybe not like home
games you could probably get close to 50
50 in home games but when when talking
about high stakes poker where there's a
lot of money on the line and it's really
and it's so competitive these days in
Cutthroat like it you're just it's just
not gonna happen
um and yeah so that's very long-winded
answer to say it's complicated yeah no
that makes a lot of sense um
of people who are professional pokers
these days poker players these days
how much are people making from this
like what does it take to make a
full-time living from professional poker
um
well I guess it depends where you live
right
yeah I should caveat this now I've been
out of Poker for a number of years so I
actually I don't know
um
but
from what I recently heard the most the
biggest pool of players who are still
like trying to play online or like
really really grinding
that are sort of new tend to come from
more like Eastern Europe
or poorer countries yep which makes
sense right because you know it's
harder to get by on you know you can get
by on small amount of money there so it
makes sense for more people to go into
um you know into something like poker uh
but yeah there's no there's no clear
answer it's almost to your personal
circumstances right
and I guess if you're like let's say top
10 poker players in the world are these
guys making like hundreds of thousands
or like Millions like tens of millions
like what kind of ballpark are we
talking in terms of I guess
profitability so like Peak poker times
let's say like
2011-12 that's when all like the
nosebleeds uh we call them nosebleeds
games like the super high stakes online
games were happening
um
they were making tens of millions wow
well yeah certainly like around 10
million and then but this is all the
like sort of well-known ones probably
the biggest winners in poker are the
people who've been playing Just Like
These underground big cash games with
what we call Wales the lingo is you've
got fish who are like the bad players
the amateurs you've got sharks who are
the pros and then you've got whales who
are the very wealthy fish yep that makes
sense yeah
um and you know a lot of poker players
some perhaps even some of the best poker
players we've probably never even heard
of because they are the ones who they
never play anything public they're just
seeking out these very juicy big cash
games against very wealthy people yeah
who knows how much they're winning there
yeah
um and or they might not even be Pros
you know maybe the biggest winner of all
times probably some wealthy businessman
um wouldn't wouldn't surprise me you
know playing
20 30 million dollar buy-in games yep
yeah but certainly in terms of like
tournament poker players then it's like
so the biggest tournament in the world
is the World Series of Poker Main Event
happens in Vegas every year
um first prize one year in that in 2006
was like 12 million dollars but it's
typically around seven eight million
um so
yeah the like the the the the most
extreme end of the bell curve will be
someone somewhere in like the 10 10 to
15 million something like that cool so
you've got your sponsorship deal right
now you're going around these
tournaments what's what's happening next
uh yeah going around the top going
around the that's where I got to like
travel so much got to go to Australia
um all over Europe
Costa Rica just having the best time and
then I'm in south of France in 2010 and
remember that Icelandic volcano yeah his
name I can have it yeah every little
exploded yeah and I was actually down
there for another reason
but I couldn't get home and I was there
with another poker player A lady called
Liz Liu and she's like well we can't
leave but there's a this big tournament
a European pocatel happening in Italy
Northern Italy should we try and let's
see if we can make it to that
um so we get French rail strike or
whatever we eventually get there on the
train
um and I get remember we get there just
in time for me to enter this satellite
tournament to the main event so it's a
500 euro buy-in
um
one in ten people win their 5 000 Euro
seat and that's how much the buy-in is
for the main event and I win it at like
four in the morning
and then I play the next day at noon
and I think it's only like my second or
third
EPT the European Poker Tour event where
it's like this so I'm not comfortable
there's much higher Stakes than I'm used
to playing really it's a 5 000 Euro
buy-in
um fairly inexperienced at it
and
long story short after six days of
playing I end up winning the whole thing
no for 1.25 million euros bloody hell
damn okay what was that like mad
absolutely insane
um
yeah because especially as I didn't even
plan to play you know sorry I win my
seat so intently the 500 euros into the
5 000 and then you know day one was like
whatever I made it through but then day
two I think I got quite a decent chip
stack but then day three which is where
there's like it had 1280 entrance and I
think
you know the money bubble as we called
it where you can start getting payout
from that point onwards was about 230
people and I was around ship leader from
that point onwards so I made it into the
money day three day four and I remember
that final the night before the final
table
so there was nine of us left
uh and that meant that going into the
next day I was guaranteed for ninth I
think around 80 000 Euros which was
probably double roughly what I had in my
bank account at the time so already just
like again we're talking life-changing
money here
um
uh
that night I think the sort of talking
about like playing poker in your head I
I don't even know if I slept frankly
because it was just all I could see was
poker hands and these scenarios and I
was so nervous the next day walking to
the tournament I had to stop like
multiple times to throw up wow yeah yeah
like nerves Beyond nerves but when I
actually sat down and like felt the
cards in my hand just in the zone and
the nerves sort of disappeared not
completely you know definitely a
heightened state
but you just sort of entered this Flow
State I guess at least that was my
experience and it all went right and I
won
what was your um do you have like a sort
of pregame ritual or things to get you
into the zone you know like Michael
Phelps does this thing right everyone
seems to have a routine of some sort I
think I was doing a meditation thing at
the time where I'd listen to this track
for 30 minutes where it was like have a
chime so
okay
pretty sure I had something like that
going on but I didn't have any
particular ritual I certainly did later
on in my career
um
I would have like certain music I would
listen listen to metal song by band
called children of Bodum it would just
like pump me up give me energy uh
I'd have a mantra
um for a little while I worked with a
with a sort of with a coach
um and the Mantra we developed was
I can't remember it now but it was
something like
I will not worry about the results I
will focus on my process and the results
will take care of themselves you know so
getting you into that process focused
mindset
um which was so helpful
um yoga
try and sleep well although never been
very good at that
um yeah the usual stuff I mean there was
a real shift again around sort of 2010
where before you know the top Pros would
be
you know they're playing until all hours
of the night they drink you know
whatever whatever and then there was
sudden like wellness push where the top
Pros started treating themselves you
know like like professional athletes and
you notice the difference like people
like all of a sudden everyone was
getting into yoga a lot of them are
meditating they're very healthy getting
really fit and strong
um and people just it was it was really
impressive and I certainly got into that
a lot more yeah and it helped
surprise surprise take care of your body
and your mind you know follows along
surprise
um
what were the feelings going the
thoughts and feelings going through your
mind as you're sitting there and as
you're I guess as the game is
progressing and you're thinking oh [__]
I might actually win this
can you remember what that was like
well
so I've told this story a couple of
times so the funny thing is is that
on the very day one of that tournament
right before the cards would the first
cards were dealt
I had a voice in my head that came
seemingly out of nowhere that said I
can't remember it said you or I which
seems kind of critical but to the effect
of you are going to win this tournament
and I got this like wave of Goosebumps
so
imagine that sort of being in the back
of your mind throughout the tournament
sort of giving it I didn't it was such a
strange experience that I didn't know
whether to take it seriously I was just
like okay cool but it definitely gave me
this like sense of calm like
I don't need to worry too much like the
this is mine this is my one to win
and when things got stressful which they
invariably do like you lose half your
you you know it's not like a smooth
sales you know as you slowly accumulate
everyone's chips until you're the last
man standing you're only like double up
oh lose it all you know lose 80 backup
and but as long as the trend is this
and having that in the back of my mind
definitely like took the edge off the
nerves when I would like lose a big pot
um it just gave this additional sort of
layer of confidence and yeah and then I
ended up winning it so I don't even know
what that was
um you know the logical explanation is
is that it's something I would have
experienced before every tournament and
I only happen to remember that because I
won that one but I really don't think
that's the case because I've won other
things and I never had the same
experience so
the biggest arguably the biggest mystery
of my life yeah I was gonna ask you more
about this so uh was it you who told
that story of having a friend who the
energy healer sucked something out of
their ear because I I can't was it Tim
Ferriss or was it like less I think I
put it on both actually yeah like I
remember I remember hearing that a few
months ago and just I still think about
that every every few days I'm just like
there's something around energy and the
spirituality stuff is like something
there and I've kind of vaguely dabbled
with meditation and like read waking up
and stuff it's just it seems like such
this world of interesting stuff that I'm
just like once I finish my book I just
want to explore this area and just go
all in like what sort of Explorations
have you done in in the field of the
occult yeah I mean do you want me to
tell the story yeah
please
um so
yeah this this air thing that happened
was
um
I've been having
it was 2018
and one morning I woke up and I was
having sort of sound Distortion it was I
felt like something like my ear was
muffled
um I couldn't hear properly like low
frequencies it was like having cotton
wool in there but then on top of that
certain sounds would be really distorted
in a very unpleasant way particularly
men's voices
um and it was really upsetting because I
I I you know I'm a pretty social person
and whenever it was happening I couldn't
go to parties or anything because it was
it was just it was so unbearable it was
like simultaneously being deaf but also
having a megaphone of like in a really
unpleasant way
um and it would come in clusters like I
would have it for a few days and it
would disappear and it would come back
again and I went and saw doctors and
doctors and the
in the end it seemed like the diagnosis
was many heirs which you know for those
who don't know it's like a pretty awful
degenerative hearing loss thing where
you'll also get like Distortion and
often like vertigo attacks
so you know we're doing tons of research
like is there anything you can do about
this no it's incurable you can maybe try
and manage it but
um cut to like three months later and
Matt Burning Man and I'd actually had
like another attack of it and including
some vertigo
so I was like so down in the dumps I
remember in the last night of the burn
the burn Burning Man and
I get talking to this girl now I was not
sober take that for what it will but I
uh I was talking to this girl and I
mentioned about my ear and she's like
well I've done some energy healing do
you want me to have a go I was like sure
now I was as skeptical as you get about
this stuff even though I had that weird
poker tournament experience aside of
that you know I'd like I've called
myself a rationalist physics background
it's all [__] woo-woo nonsense no
time for this stuff
but I was in such a desperate State I
was like sure have a go
not expecting anything and she's like
feeling around over my ear with her hand
um you know it's kind of in the dark so
memory's a little slightly hazy but I
remember him being there and she's like
oh there's something there let me I'm
gonna have to do this it's gonna be
unpleasant and she leans in and starts
like over my ear
with her mouth and I'm like please stop
because it's like loud like I don't like
this she's like I've got to get it she
does this for a few minutes and then
sort of drops to the floor freezing cold
very scared like seemingly scared and
like discomfort and she's like oh this
is horrible okay and then after we sort
of try and warm her up and make her feel
better after about 20 minutes and she's
like well
I've definitely pulled something out of
you it's gone you don't need to worry
about it
um
uh and I was like and at this point I'm
now like really freaked out because I've
never seen anything like this uh and she
I remember asking I was like well at
least am I is my ear better she's like
yeah your physical symptoms will last
for a couple of weeks probably and then
you'll be fine and that's exactly what
happened
my hearing is
I had a hearing test for I don't know
six months ago no noticeable loss
so
what the [__]
and it was
again talk about like Paradigm shifting
moment like it just blew
my entire understanding of what might be
reality open because I was like wait it
maybe energies are real and not only
that maybe you can have negative ones or
positive you know they could be positive
or negative and and you could fix things
in another way a side of Medicine
and it was so
I mean it was disorienting for a while
frankly like I went through a bit of
just being very scared of like okay well
you know
I being like concerned about like what
energies am I letting into myself and so
on
um and then sort of found a middle
ground of
I guess
you know poker teaches you to think
about things probabilistically right
you'll never you can never be certain
about anything like I I think you're
Bluff I I haven't as my prediction is
you're bluffing me here with like 30
confidence something like that it's 40
of the time you have a better hand or
whatever
that's how I now approach this stuff I
think
with some percentage and it depends on
the day that there's a classical
explanation for what happened was that
you know maybe I was in such a
heightened State you know Placebo maybe
I'd had like a viral infection which
actually just that's what was the cause
and it faded away there's all of those
probabilities and like I I'm certainly
willing to entertainment but you know if
PRI if my prior before that the energy
healing was a thing was around you know
one in a million yeah let's say it's now
shifted to
honestly like 40 which is a huge like
orders of magnitude change
um also because now since I've been like
more open to it I've noticed you know
I've I've paid attention to like other
friends who did
dealt with similar things and it clearly
brings a benefit now what's causing that
benefit I don't know but there is
Extreme value in it and I think it's
something that is worth studying so much
um and now again I want this to come
like it needs to come with a huge caveat
that like don't expect there to be a
magical sort of you know because
unfortunately after telling the story
I've had people message me like I've got
many as who was the person who did this
for you you know and I can't like I
can't give that you know I I can't help
um and I don't I want to you know I
don't know that I had many errors all I
know is that that was what the
experience was I was diagnosed with
something like it and it went away after
this but again causally we don't know
but
there's clearly potential here they're
like we really don't understand how
Consciousness works we don't understand
the power of the human mind anywhere
near as much
um as we should and it is so worthy of
study
that we we need to just it
it feels like this
there's a sort of
unfortunately a lot of the people who
are best equipped to actually sort of
apply the scientific method to this
stuff are not open to even considering
it in the first place and that's where
we need to address that's the sort of
imbalance we need to address
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been able
paying customer of wework for the last
two years now I discovered it during you
know when the pandemic was in the on the
verge of being lifted and I spent like
the whole year just sort of sitting in
my room making YouTube videos but then I
discovered wework and I was a member of
me and Angus my team members we were
members of the wework in Cambridge and
they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone on my team has is the
all-access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop up with
me I've got some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've got soundproof booths in
which they take Zoom calls and meetings
anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode so
you become an overnight millionaire
sorry were you gonna say something uh
well I was gonna say another thing I
found that actually helps me uh and I've
noticed help other friends if you're
having anxiety
sounds dumb but like dropping to the
ground Barefoot ideally outside grass
Barefoot hands and feet
and just like sort of rock backwards and
forwards and push into the ground
and just imagine your anxiety is just
being dissipated into the Earth kind of
like a you know
a lightning rod essentially you know
you're grounding yep
does the trick yeah
so
you become an overnight millionaire
thanks for winning this tournament
what was that like
the next week after that win was
again one of the most insane weeks
imaginable because
uh
I don't know whether it was because the
papers picked up on it themselves or
because of the tournament organizer
pushed it you know made a press release
but
somehow it got into the into the
national papers especially especially in
the UK
uh you know because I was just like
strange looking 25 year old girl come
out of nowhere wins a million pounds in
a poker tournament and that's cool yeah
yeah it was a good story and so there
was like a period of like four or five
days where I was on the Frank front page
of almost every major newspaper
like the Daily Mail turned up like they
found out my parents address and turned
up at the house
um came and took pictures of my like
childhood pictures Grant you know
graduation pictures and and I mean it
was fun it was really cool but it was
just like my phone was ringing non-stop
for interviews
um so that was very intense and very you
know it was it was definitely enjoyable
uh and then
after that that was yeah so this was
when I was like oh no maybe poker stars
because that was that was their
tournament as well and remember I said
that had always been my goal to become a
team pro for them uh and a few months
later you know they offered me a a spot
on their roster so uh then I joined them
and then for the next few years you know
played as one of their team Pros
um and it was some of the best years of
my life
just like it's like this big traveling
family
um of you know some of my closest
friends who continue to be good friends
to this day where we were just you know
okay see you in
see you in Australia see you in Vegas
see you in Monaco
um and you know you just followed the
tour playing in the events doing you
know doing media that kind of stuff
um yeah
did the
that initial windfall change your
relationship with money in any way
no not that much weirdly like I I'd
always been we have a term in poker
where you call someone who's like kind
of tight and cautious with money a net
and I'd been on the nettier side of
things throughout uh it was it was a
weird sort of false scarcity mindset
frankly I was definitely a bit tighter
with money than I should have been
um and it did it took me a while to sort
of
you know I definitely didn't suddenly go
all right let's go crazy
um in terms of like buying lavish things
um I've never been into like
particularly brands or you know
expensive clothing or anything like that
um I didn't even buy a new car in fact
for like a while uh what I didn't spend
money on was like I bought a house I
bought an apartment in London
um which was you know that was nice and
my parents were very pleased
something sensible please okay so
um so yeah I can't say my attitude to
money changed that much but what did
change was my attitude to Poker
particularly my attitude to learning you
know studying and working hard because
kind of like you know on that TV show
back in 2005 where I had the the win I
was like well I guess I'm God's gift
that old uh on Health on unhelpful Meme
sort of resurfaced in my head and I was
like well I must be the best at this
because like or at least I must be in so
insanely talented to win such a big
tournament still relatively early on um
so I became a bit just got a bit lazy
for a period of time
uh and
that you know like with many things if
you don't carry on studying everyone
else is studying so the game will slowly
start to overtake you and and that
coupled with a bit of regression to the
mean
that like the next year actually my well
next six or seven months my results were
definitely sub like sub-optimal
um and it was a bit of a again I needed
another wake-up call
yeah in this on this occasion with some
friends sort of sitting me down and
going live you you need to carry on
studying like you did just it was just
one tournament don't get deluded by you
know that that incredible success
um so that was another nice little life
life lesson period
so you won this tournament 2010 and then
I guess you become a member of the poker
stars pokerstar Squad and then what's
what is the rest of the
thing look like so that carries on
um in terms of just poker I was sort of
concurrently doing trying to get into uh
TV presenting so I was doing presenting
in poker like
um interviewing people introducing the
show Etc uh but I started feeling uh I
started missing science again frankly uh
and
so started doing the occasional
science TV
hosting and you know completely
unrelated things from poker and I loved
that and
um
and then around 2014
is when uh Igor and I get introduced to
effective altruism cool and we decided
to start an organization that basically
encourages poker players to donate a
portion of their winnings to the most
cost-effective Charities yeah how did
you get into effective altruism
um so well first I'll Define what it is
because you know some people have
probably heard of it and there's a lot
of like confusing
yeah people don't seem to have a clear
definition of it but at least my
definition of it is
it's basically the question of like
applying the well given there are so
many different problems in the world so
many
um and ideally we would be able to fix
them all straight away but because we
have limited resources time money brain
power
um we have to kind of triage these these
problems and figure out which ones you
know are most urgent which affect the
most people
um and which we can actually make a
difference on and so effective altruism
is essentially just that that process of
of trying to
use logic and reason to figure out how
to best allocate resources
um and so it's like it's like the
scientific method applied to
philanthropy and it like just it deeply
resonated with you know me and Egon and
Phil and Stefan who was you know the
other two co-founders of the org
um like Stefan he'd be actually been
doing it for a while he was giving away
like huge percentages I think almost all
of his winnings above a certain amount
to these cost-effective Charities
because he's just like well look I don't
need more than this and I you know the
the evidence is out there like for every
roughly around four thousand five
thousand dollars you donate say to
against malaria Foundation you on
expectation save a literal life
so it's like would you you know if you
saw someone dying in the street and it
would mean that you would I know would
you sacrifice your car to like save
someone who you see is about to die
probably right not always again I'm not
saying you have to do that but the point
is
for every four thousand dollars you
donate you will on expectations save a
life so it's just like
from his perspective he's like okay well
I'm going to be donating you know this
made enough sense to him that he
decided to sort of dedicate his poker
career to making as much as he could to
give away and
we he introduced us to these this this
group of uh Swiss philosophers whose
full-time living was researching
basically what are the most cost
effective
um Charities you know what are the best
ways to improve the world
and it and it just resonated so much
that we decided to you know try and
basically bring this to the poker
Community because we felt like these
these Concepts would resonate a lot with
poker players who are used to thinking
in terms of return on investment
expected value
um you know
allocating their personal time and money
as best in the most sort of cost
efficient and effective manner
um to maximize their profits at the
poker table when it's the same process
for like your charitable giving and it
you know by and large poker players you
know they got it uh they they really
resonated as well so we started this
thing called raising for Effective
giving absolutely pun on you know
raising Etc oh yeah and um
so we
to be a member
a pledge to say you'll donate at least
two percent of your winnings
um I think it's quarterly or annually
um or whatever you felt but basically
just join the movement and like give
what you can
um and
uh over you know by the time we sort of
all quit poker and we sort of sunsetted
it back in like 2019 uh it moved about
14 million dollars to these Charities
pretty like counter Factory as well like
money that wouldn't have gone
um and then even better uh Dan Smith
who's another very very successful poker
player uh sort of took these same
principles and started his own thing
called double up Drive which has been
even more successful I don't know like I
think it's in a probably over 20 million
dollars he's moved
um to again like
very cost effective Charities a lot of
them similar ones overlapping to what
reg was doing um which is our our
organization
um
but yeah so that was that was a really
interesting sort of moment in my career
because up until then really everything
I'd been doing was very Zero Sum right
poker is by definition zero-sum game yep
you know I win you lose
and I
it was around sort of
that time around 2013 where I was like
it's like is this really what I want to
do for the mic is that's what I want on
my gravestone you know she was really
good at check raising people in this
certain position like you know the world
seems to be more of a positive something
I think there's probably better uses of
what I'm doing than just playing
um and yeah so for a period of time
raising for Effective giving sort of
found a way to like make a win-win after
what seems like a win news game yeah
yeah because I guess you know as we
talked about at the start the stuff that
you're a super into now is kind of
raising awareness of positive some uh
kind of situations and win-win thinking
yeah
having it as just a philosophy like a
sort of a guide star like is what I'm
doing a win-win thing or is it a
win-lose or actually could it be a
lose-lose and like really trying to be
honest with yourself to think about the
externalities of whatever it is you're
doing because in reality there's no such
thing as an actual zero-sum game like
it in in in in physicality I should say
you know if we play a game of chess yes
technically
one of us will win one will lose
um so that evens out but
in practicality there are external you
know we'll both get better at chess
maybe we'll become better friends maybe
we'll actually hate each other you know
have a big argument
um so there's always externalities even
to these zero-sum games that we might
play and it's
I think an error to not truly Factor
those in and we can expand the
definition of games as well like
you know
technically any kind of interaction that
you do you could consider it as a game
you know so if you are a Trader yeah
technically you're playing the trading
game if you're a scientist
it's you're playing the science game
um you know and certainly some
Industries are more like inclined to be
positive some or negative some
um but it's it's it's important that we
sort of just take a step back and really
ask ourselves that you know whether
whether the industry that we are you
know or the career path we are choosing
is actually going to benefit the world
are we are we just optimizing for what's
like the short-term win game for us
um and it's like it's okay you know if
you if you do decide no you know what I
just want to do something that is
immediately beneficial to me
um I'm not saying that's wrong but like
don't delude yourself that you're doing
something good at least just like have
that as an awareness in your back in the
back of your mind
how does poker with Partners work people
with Partners yeah as an is is there
like a tag team type situation well or
no not usually okay
um but there is a particular format
called you know called tag team poker
which
um
I mean varies but the way the one
uh are you asking because of the
tournament I won yeah 21 with with
partner and boyfriend Igor yeah yeah
what was that uh so the way that one
worked was in between hands so not
during a hand but in between a hand uh
at the end of a hand you could tap out
and tag your partner in and you had to
both play a minimum amount throughout
the tournament
um but yeah Igor and I won our bracelets
in in that bracelet yeah so there's a if
you win a World Series of Poker yep
tournament then it's called winning a
bracelet and you get this like gold
bracelet thing yeah and that was again
one of my biggest goals in poker was to
win a bracelet and so for us to win both
our first bracelets together was just
painfully cute yeah
um and yeah it was really really fun how
did your New York meet uh we met through
poker funny enough actually we the first
times we have a cross paths as far as we
know was on like day three of that big
European poker tournament in Italy
um he says he remembers me I I don't
actually remember him apparently we're
only at the table you know against each
other for a couple of hours
um and I think I won a couple of parts
off him but uh yeah I mean I presumably
stuck out you know very few girls
playing and then I win the tournament
um so that was when we first crossed
files but we uh we became friends
sometime in like 2012.
um and again yeah we just became really
good friends he lived near me in London
um and it wasn't until like
being friends for a couple of years that
we ever like got romantic
um and actually I was kind of like
resistant to it because it was like he
was such a close friend I was like no no
this is weird like you know you're
almost like
you're my bro like uh but there was
clearly something there and then when it
did turn romantic it was just like oh
obviously yeah and then we've just been
Inseparable since oh nice yeah because
people often want uh often worry about
that I think girls in particular worry
about that situation more than guys do
around like oh but we're good friends
and this could potentially ruin a
friendship yeah yeah
um I guess it's worked out well it's one
of those I guess risks that well it was
partly because I was just like
I wanted to be single for a while
um you know I hadn't had much time
single and just wanted to sort of
I'd had like a bad come out of a bad
relationship and and
he I I knew that if we did ever turn
romantic it was going to be a big deal
either way and I just loved our
friendship that we had and um and I
think he felt the same way too you know
not saying it was all one-way Street or
anything
um but
uh yeah I don't know it was it was
definitely very
in this again selection bias like I'm
coming from you know this happened to be
the one that worked out so well
um but it it was just it was just that
like uh duh when when we finally were
like okay we're a thing yeah
um and yeah it was great so unit Igor
started playing then together as like
tag team partners well no so that that
tag team tournament I think that was the
first year they ever ran it right
um as far as them were and it's it's a
very rare like it's literally like
I mean it's probably like one in a
thousand but less even oh okay one in
five thousand poker tournaments are
attack team they're really just like
they're kind of like a novelty style of
event
um so it is poker is very much an
individualistic game but that doesn't
mean that like
poker players don't benefit from you
know not at the table but us when you
know when they're away doing their
homework working together kind of as
like a you know as a Brain Trust as a
research group there's a lot of that
um especially sort of back in you know
around the 2010s there would be like
just you know oh the Germans who are the
best at the moment I was the Germans are
the best yeah yeah and they like you'd
see the different sort of strategies
arise out of the different groups
um because you know like with so many
problems more Minds more minds are
better than one yeah
um and there was there's there's long
been this like really collaborative
Spirit within the game which is also
then so interesting because you know
they'll be best friends
who've been studying together but then
they'll end up at the table against each
other oh yeah and then the gloves are
off you know at least but it should be
off
um and like certainly Igor and I on the
rare occasions where we have ended up at
the same table as each as each other
oh
if anything we go after each other
harder than others
you know partly because people are
always like scrutinizing you like oh
well you know you're a couple that's
this is so you have to really make sure
that you do but the foundation of our
relationship is on
competition
we also we've we find a way to turn
competitive we find a way to
turn almost every Endeavor into some
kind of competition we gamify everything
even like we're really into bouldering
right now and we [__] talk at each other
non-stop like that it's truly like oh
that's our love language
[Music]
um because we're just both incredibly
competitive people and
I think that that's one of the cool
things about poker players is that they
find a way to like
compartmentalize
you know again like best friends can be
playing against each other like bluffing
the hell out of one another taking money
like getting under each other's skin and
then once you leave the tournament
they're like I'm around each other oh
are you in that handed oh yeah but I
would have done that this way
and you know drinking and then they're
back at it again the next day and it's
it's such a it's a really hard skill to
cultivate but I think it's a really
important one to be able to go okay well
this is where we express this
competitive side of our nature but then
still value cool you know collaboration
Above All Else yeah
so in 2019 uh you announced that you
were gonna quit professional poker
what led to that being the decision I
get in how long were you playing for at
that point like over a decade oh yeah
yeah uh yeah like Pro
yeah like 11 years or so 12 years
um I've been starting to lose my fire
for poker sort of from 2015 onwards
honestly
um because you know as I mentioned
before it the the way that the game was
played and studied had just drastically
shifted
um into this more
more like rote learning at least that's
how it felt
and and less it felt like it was getting
sort of less creative it was like you
now we understood the mechanics of how
the game plays you see the rabbit hole
and the question is do you want to go
down the rabbit hole and so it kind of
like took away a bit of the mystery and
it was you know again less about sort of
people reading and even though that's
still important you know you couldn't
make it as a player like a top Pro
unless you were really studying the
charts as well and it just
I don't know whether that was you know
whether my sort of loss of love for the
game around that time was because of
that or maybe just because I've been
doing it too long you know all things we
tend to get bored of things eventually
um but either way I just started losing
interest to like try and stay on top
um not that I ever was on top but you
know like stay the best version of my
myself that I could be as a player
um and you know frankly I I kind of wish
I'd quit earlier than 2019. you know it
was it was sort of like it was just like
a cushy life you know I still had my
sponsorship deal
um
I couldn't imagine another life from
that so much of my identity was wrapped
up in you know as live the poker Pro who
goes on tour and go you know I couldn't
like wait I would I would miss the uh I
I would miss the EPT Final in Monaco
like inconceivable I've been going for
the last nine years all my friends are
gonna be there am I really not going to
go
um and so it's kind of hard to make that
leap and I see a lot of poker players
frankly today who are like
going through the same thing and it's
just so hard to hang up your hat because
it's like you're now stepping into the
big unknown you're a big fish in a small
pond and now you're a tiny fish in an
ocean of uncertainty which frankly we
should be good at dealing with but it's
it's still hard
um
but yeah and and it was I I mean I
technically like stopped playing
properly sort of around 2018 frankly but
it was I think it was 2019 when my poke
Stars contract expired and they didn't
want to renew and frankly I don't know
if I would have wanted to and I'm glad
you know it was it was time
uh to move on but yeah it's hard and it
was only it was funny I went back and
played in uh December
for the first time in ages
and I was playing this lovely Big World
Poker Tour Championship and you know the
players on you know on average were very
amateur
and I was like wow
I'm not any better than most of these
people anymore like right the muscle
memory has just while it's still there
like it's just so Rusty and like
struggling to add you know I used to be
able to add up the pot like that like
instantaneous count combos boom and it
was just like I could hear the rusty
gears like drying but not even really
not sure if they can remember how to
and it was a nice moment I was like I'm
not a good poker player anymore great
and it was actually very freeing just
being able to like say that to myself
and say it out loud because it was such
a big part of my identity
um yeah
how did you navigate that identity that
sudden loss of identity when you no
longer this this life that you've been
leading for 11 years
is no longer your day-to-day
it was it was actually easier than I
expected it to be like the anticipation
of it was worse than the reality
um you know it partly coincided with
um
yeah it sort of coincided with my
I met a new group of friends around both
eager and I met a new group of friends
around that time and they were just like
clear we were clearly being pulled in a
sort of more you know a different
direction uh more you know again a more
positive some direction yeah to do you
know to try and help
help with some of these big sort of uh
catastrophic risks the the that we're
facing you know and we felt you know we
both felt both felt so pulled to go into
that it it like I guess lubricated the
ride out
um so yeah it was it wasn't too hard
how much how much was money a decision
in terms of like deciding what you
needed to do next or like had you made
enough from poker to just not have to
work like
what was the vibe yeah I mean certainly
not enough to like retire from yeah but
enough to be like I can take a year or
two and breathe right yes okay take a
couple of years to breathe
um and think about you know what what's
what's the next thing yeah and actually
this this coincide another thing that
made it easier
I started giving talks
as a sort of you know a way of
disseminating the thinking lessons that
poker had taught me
um I gave a TED Talk
um and turns out that you do a TED talk
it's a really really good
um Sizzle reel yep for companies you
know to show companies hey look I can
talk about this stuff would you like me
to come and talk to your to your
employees or to your clients yes we
would and we'll pay you some money
um so
simultaneously my speaking career
started sort of taking off
um and I guess like you know as a as a
public intellectual whatever you want to
call it yeah that again helps soften the
blow because I could like I still could
sort of somewhat have the Hat of I'm I'm
a pro poker player but without actually
having to play and instead actually
doing something more useful again much
more useful yeah it's much more positive
some use of of the sort of
of the game
so over the last few years it seems like
you've taken a big interest in AI in
particular or potentially over the last
few months I've just seen a few YouTube
videos and you've mentioned in
interviews and on socials how did the
interest in AI start
I mean it started I guess around you
know when I first
learned about effective altruism and you
know when on a reading spiral of all the
all the different sort of directions
that you can take because you know
there's so much what's so cool about the
effects of altruism Community is that
there's like very little agreement
because it's because it's so difficult
you know that it's we don't even know
what correct moral framework is you know
is it deontology is it virtue ethics is
it utilitarianism we don't know but
let's try and figure it out and so you
know some people come to the conclusion
that actually the most effective thing
we can do is like Global Health in the
world's poorest countries you know
poverty alleviation really strong
Arguments for that there's really strong
arguments that actually you know the
same amount of money can save a thousand
times as many animals from like a life
of torture on a factory farm there's a
strong moment for that there's also a
strong argument that actually the best
thing is you know these it seems like
there's a problem a growing probability
that we go extinct from our own
Technologies
over the next Century so actually that's
the most expected value High expected
value thing you can do and there's
there's so much disagreement amongst
that so in reading all of the arguments
for these things one that pops up is
like
where you seem to be on this inexorable
March of creating more and more powerful
artificial intelligence and
there there's a possibility that if you
buy you know if you if you do
successfully build something that by
definition is super intelligent is much
more in you know orders of magnitude
more intelligent than any of us that for
the same reason
even though a chimpanzee is much
physically stronger than a human
we can just draw a fence around it and
control it because we're much smarter it
will be able to we it will be able to do
things and predict things that we
couldn't even dream of so we're
essentially creating a kind of alien god
and that's like the most high stakes
thing that's ever happened on Earth
we should probably even if we think it's
only a small chance of happening we
should probably spend at least some
resources on making sure that goes well
because there's no guarantee that super
you know intelligence correlates with
like wisdom or kindness or fairness or
caring about biological matter or even
existing
you know because a super intelligence an
AI lives off silicon we rely on carbon
so we're fundamentally operating on
different substrates so there's a chance
this might not go well and even if you
think that chance is very very tiny you
know considering we're spending like
500 million on lipstick a year maybe we
should just put a little bit you know
into this yeah
um so that was sort of what got me
thinking and also because the other the
other interesting thing about AI as well
it's not all potentially negative it
could be the best thing we ever make as
well it might be the answer to so many
of our problems because so many of these
issues that we're facing are our
inability to coordinate
there are so many you know there's eight
billion of us on this planet all with
conflicting interests and desires even
though we're on the big picture we
actually all want the same thing we all
want love and
an oxygen-rich environment and food and
shelter and and you know the the
hierarchy of needs
but
on a short term sort of day-to-day scale
we all have differing incentives and
we're all playing sort of Trapped in
different games whether it's a
money-making game or the prestige game
or whatever
and how do we navigate this when we're
simultaneously
giving more and more power
which could be used for good but also
could be used for massive destruction to
more and more people
um so you know once you sort of go down
the rabbit hole of that it's hard to see
it you know it's like this like how can
we be thinking about anything about this
um at least again not saying that's what
you have to do but that was my
experience
um
yeah what was I going with that we're
talking about kind of how you first got
interested in the AI stuff I guess
through the effect of altruism route
yeah so I mean that was just one of the
things that like stuck out I was like
wow this is a big deal and I remember
reading like
um a lot of Elias yukowski's writing on
less wrong which talks about
um you know he's been sounding the alarm
on on AI since the early 2000s
and you know it's like okay yeah this
makes sense again even if we give it a
low probability we need some people to
be thinking about it and especially like
even today when people have been talking
about AI safety now for years
the ratio of like money that's spent on
pure progress versus safety is like
500 to one yeah certainly more than 100
to one it might be thousands to one
frankly
so there's like this huge gap
where there's like someone it's so
desperately needed more people working
on on the just the sort of the safety
side of stuff What's called the
alignment problem getting it to be
aligned with what's good for Humanity
um
and you know that's not to say I'm like
not knocking any like the companies that
are working on AGI development you know
artificial general intelligence you know
the ones that are currently leading the
charge
um you know certainly the folks at
deepmind like they're thinking about
this deeply deeply deeply but they're
just one company there's so many others
that are all now trying to be there
first and
again coordination problem how do you
how do you
They're all playing this game of who can
get there how do you keep the
externalities to a minimum the negative
externalities if everyone's optimizing
for Speed
because if you know like well if we
don't get there first they're going to
get their first Donuts yeah so yeah uh
it's it's it's a challenge yeah no
absolutely
um I guess yeah especially it's it's it
seems like the AI progress conversation
has really been kickstarted in the last
few months with the whole like gpt3 chat
GPT type stuff and now everyone on
Twitter is like oh my God like now we
see the power of AI right finally people
are waking up to it Space Invaders and
like okay fine but I was like oh [__]
like this is actually replacing people's
jobs and oh right I can ask it a
question and it responds like a human
yeah it was like it's giving something
because the thing is like the the sort
of the super intelligence thing you know
the AGI yeah
I mean it's fair it is fair to question
that it might not even be possible you
know but what's the you know watch at
GPT and and Dolly and all of these have
shown as like we don't even you know we
don't even have to get to AGI to know
that this is going to be the most the
the AIS we're having now are clearly
going to disrupt industry after industry
after industry
and it's like at an at an accelerating
rate of change
and we are just not reacting fast enough
to this
um in terms of like if you care about
sort of stability to an extent and we
need some degree of stability like
um you know I'm not saying we should
just like stay in lockstep with what
we're currently doing really we need to
fix a lot of things but
again fine line between Order and Chaos
and we've got to mitigate the chaos
Direction a little bit
nice so we talked to um at the start
around kind of your I guess day job
being uh with the Center for Effective
altruism is that right yeah well so uh
uh I
um I guess technically I'm an employee
uh an ambassador
for Longview philanthropy
um whose main focus is existential risk
reduction
you know how do we mitigate so many of
these
growing threats not only from emerging
technology but climate change
environmental destruction
so that
the next couple of generations
have a world to live in yeah
um and again it's there's a lot of
dissent you know about is are these
threats happening in the next 10 years
or are they happening in the next
hundred years in my opinion there's not
much difference between the two I mean
the 10 years affects me personally but
like I intend to have children probably
so I would like them to have a life and
their grandkids
um but it you know it's it's anyone who
says to you oh we're fine the next the
next 20 years are fine like their head
is in the sand or anyone who says to you
we're definitely going to die in the
next five years they're a little
overconfident the point is there's
enough uncertainty that it's it's
clearly a big problem and so yeah long
views uh focus is mitigating these risks
um but usually through like advising
donors on on opportunities to you know
what good projects to fund um another
big area that's really like should be on
all of our minds is like pandemic
preparedness
like
covert is small fry
compared to what could potentially be
coming because again we are developing
more and more you know with biotech
developments more and more capabilities
that over time will become more and more
available to more people
um and we are you know whether you
believe covert was natural origin or lab
leak doesn't really matter the point is
at some point the probability of
artificially
enhanced or entirely synthesized
pathogens
is going to be widespread and you know
if it falls into the wrong hands that
would be concerning so
um
yeah that's another very neglected cause
area
um but um
yeah yeah after after I went to the
Longview Retreat a few months ago I
ended up reading a book uh the Bomb by
Fred Kaplan which is about the history
of the nuclear bomb and how that's uh
progressed from World War II onwards
till now and that was really scary and
so ring as well like oh my God it's not
fun
it was all about my Disney film yeah
exactly let's play some Ed Sheeran yeah
good times
the trouble is with like when you talk
about when you mention like existential
risk the first thing people's minds go
to is like oh yeah asteroids oh super
volcano yep I'm like I wish it was just
those those are the easy ones because
they're coming from a single source
it's like okay there's an asteroid
coming right get together why am I going
to build a thing lasers whatever the you
know the technique at least it's like a
physical thing that you and a single
point you can work on even something
like a super volcano would still feel
probably a bit easier than these
coordinate the other risks that are
coming from coordination failure yeah
and these like again these unhealthy
competitive pressures
those are the hard ones and that's what
we need as many people thinking about
how to like how we need like a hive mind
solution essentially because it's a hive
mind problem yeah
yeah so let's say someone's listening to
this and they're like damn this is
really important what are some kind of
actions that people like normal people
can can take
I mean probably
the main
the first thing I would recommend is
just to to read so to try and understand
the problem as best possible
um or listen to so some good people
some good podcasts inside of this one
obviously to recommend um and a side of
mine that will be coming out hopefully
soon
um
are the 80 000 hours podcast absolutely
incredible really sort of very very deep
dive on sort of individual problems that
seem to be you know very high stakes
um with like leading leading experts
um and then some like General thinkers
that
have informed so much of my thinking
especially over the last few years
um
Daniel schmaxenberger
I don't know if you've heard of him uh
Jordan Hall
these guys are they they do a lot of
sort of public public-facing stuff and
they are truly some of the best like
real sort of systems thinkers like
deeply holistic thinkers who
both you know background and like
hardcore background in science technical
knowledge
um but are also willing to like they
have the again this like open-mindedness
to perhaps the more esoteric stuff
and some of uh
like I remember watching this talk by
Daniel schmachtenberger on emergence
just search for his name and then
emergency you'll find it yeah we'll put
a link down below as well um
and that sort of like it just it was
again a little light bulb moment I was
like oh there's there's some there's
some there's something here but just
listen to honestly any of his interviews
um particularly around civilizational
risk uh uh to talking about this concept
that has become referred to as molok
which is more like essentially the god
of uh unhealthy competition to give it a
face yep
um you know in reality it's just a
collection of game theoretic forces
um you know again this like what the bad
incentives that make people optimize for
the short-term goal at the cost of the
long-term whole
so a good example of mollock would be
oh no so like in terms of like a bad
system design uh is that you're in a
stadium and everyone's watching a you
know football game
everyone's sitting down so it's kind of
like a static State everyone's
reasonably comfortable but then someone
near the front you know actually they
just want like a little bit of a better
view so they stand up to just get
themselves that short-term Edge over
everyone else but because of the design
of the system that forces the people
behind them to stand up you know they
have a choice like if they want to
continue sort of playing the game and
watch you know in this case you know
continue watching the game they have to
stand up too but then they screw the
people behind them and so on until you
know that one person sort of
selfish action of course is everyone to
have to stand up and there's no way for
everyone to then sit down again without
some like God's eye view like magical
coordination you know someone over the
tanoi say hey everyone sit down
um so that would be an example of like a
monarchy system where
it's very vulnerable it's very easy to
like it's like a ball perch on top of a
on top of a hill yep it's not in a it's
not in an equilibrium where it's in the
bottom where it's like stable it's
actually a very unstable equilibrium and
it just takes a little nudge from like
one slightly selfish act for the whole
thing to fall down and unfortunately
that's how so many of our systems are
designed they're not in a stable
equilibrium at the bottom of a hill
they're like precariously balanced like
uh and
so that that's sort of one definition of
Malik right and then another way of
thinking about this like unhealthy
competition thing is like the uh
the sort of mindset that gives rise to
people doing that because again even
with that football situation
if the person at the front had just a
little bit more like awareness and were
a little bit less you know
self-interested and just thought about
how they're you know how this would
affect the entire system then also the
problem wouldn't have happened so
defeating this this like is the
technical word for it is a multi-polar
trap
um you know which uh just just Google it
um but
sorry
the yeah the technical term for this
thing is is this phenomenon is a
multi-polar trap but it's a bit of a
mouthful and I like uh there was this
really great blog actually this is what
people should go and read to understand
this blog called meditations on mollock
uh written by Scott Alexander
uh his website was once called slay star
codex it's now astral code X10 but just
Google meditations on molok and read
that
that is the best primer to this like
this these forces of game theory that
create so many of these these sort of
issues in our society and it the same
thing applies you know as I mentioned
before deforestation the farmer might he
might not want to cut down the forest on
his on his land but
he needs to make money and it's the most
valuable resource he has and he's like
well look I'm it's only this little
patch doesn't mean everything else is
going to go but if everyone thinks that
way then and you know if he does if his
neighbor does it well now he's
definitely got to do it because his
neighbor's getting richer and
um so it's you know once you see this
thing you know once you understand the
process behind it
you every time you see there's an issue
like it more often than not it's caused
by this same process so to create a sort
of sustainable Society moving forward we
need to figure out how to solve these
coordination problems
so that can come either I guess through
people becoming more aware of them and
their own molokian incentives or
whatever the phrases
um yeah also systems design like the
tanoi guy being like hang on I have the
chance to influence everyone right well
that would be a very like top-down
centralized approach but even better
would be to just redesign the stadium
somehow and I don't know what that would
look like redesign the landscape of the
system so that
it doesn't just take one person to like
defect essentially you know do the [__]
do the selfish action in the prisoner's
dilemma which you know this is what it
is right a multi-way presence dilemma it
we need systems that aren't vulnerable
to you know the worst the the the worst
aspects of human nature
um because that's you know well while we
can definitely raise the sanity water
line and get more people thinking in a
more like win-win way
um you know in a more like
less adversarial way we're always you
know that what is the percentage of
psychopaths in the population it's like
one percent right that
there will always be people who end up
not even that states don't really
through like bad action you know bad
intent but just because of their life
situation have no other feel like they
have no other choice
um so we need to design systems that are
robust and essentially align even the
people who only want to act selfishly
align their incentives with the good of
a whole and it's very very hard to do
but it's not impossible
and that's so that's a long way of
saying like well if you want to dive
into that stuff more I really recommend
listening to like Jordan Hall Daniel
schmachtenberger because they're like
some of the leading thinkers on that
topic
um so we talked about actually
um
I'm curious about your thoughts on
social media
um I've been a few kind of Instagram
reels that I've seen of yours where
you've basically been like social media
is bad and all of the kind of bad things
are on social media I wonder if you can
can just Riff on that from yeah
um well so it
I guess I started thinking about this
because I noticed in myself just like
I'm so horribly addicted to Twitter
it's I mean it's fascinating place but
it's like you know it's just like
watching a car crash over and over and
over
um well for two reasons a because it's
like it sucks you in
often with like the the areas that you
personally care about the most the
algorithm figures out what gets you
triggered and will show it to you over
and over because um and that's not just
true of Twitter it's true of most social
media platforms
um
and so there's that but then there's
also the like
dopamine reward system that it's got
going on in terms of like the you know
how many likes did you get and so on and
I was like you know it it started sort
of setting off the same red flags that
you know when I would have like bad days
of playing poker where I was like
chasing losses or something like that I
was like oh this is feeling a little
similar and as well caring about what my
results look like to others and like
well am I getting you know are people
talking about me for whatever they're
like they're the unhealthy aspects of
whether you're playing The Fame game or
whatever game you're playing it was like
oh this is this is a lot of the same
stuff
um
but
so I made a video again to explain this
like molok concept
um made it about a year ago called the
beauty Wars which talked about how on
Instagram I noticed
the this like explosion and popularity
of these Beauty filters
um
that weren't around like in certainly
2017 2018 uh but all of a sudden you
notice that everyone's pictures are
starting to look a little bit better and
you know I remember playing around with
these and inputting a picture of myself
which I liked but then applied the
filter to it where it just like tweaks
your eyes a little bit like this just
very subtly it's hard to pick a finger
on exactly what it's doing but it makes
you look great and it's like the Click
of a button and then you'd look at the
original picture which you loved next to
this new one you're like oh [__] that
this is great yeah and this is another
example of like one of these molarchy
processes because
even if you you know even though I was
aware of like this whole dynamic
you know at the time I was trying to
grow my Instagram be a bit of an
influencer I noticed that most of my you
know if I post a hot picture it gets a
lot more likes than one where I'm like
trying to say something intellectual so
there's like an incentive pressure to
push more hot pictures
um and then so I'm trying to play that
game and I know that everyone else is
using these things so I might as well so
then I do it but then oh there's an even
better one that comes out and so it
creates this race to the bottom scenario
which is like archetypal of molok
um
and so I made a video about that and uh
it
and yeah it's and it's and it's just
much of the same thing really it's it's
part of the problem with social media is
it reduces the richness and complexity
of The Human Experience down to like
these very narrow metrics and so by it's
by definition it's inherently
dehumanizing
um because you know I'm sure you've
noticed it in yourself right you're like
well well how many followers have I got
now and so on and it's it's even if you
are trying to be as wise and as
thoughtful about this as possible it's
such an alluring thing because it's such
a simple way of measuring success but
that loss of complexity that reduction
of information essentially about
ourselves is is is is not healthy it's
not sustainable
um and then when you couple this with uh
so this the next part in this molec
series uh video series I've been making
which will hopefully be out by this time
this video comes out it's going to be
called the media Wars
um
that the same process is happening
within our media
because you know they've always been in
a bit of competition right even since
sort of the 50s they were but they were
the competition was much less intense on
on the media uh Industries but you know
the big companies back then because
usually they had their market and it was
fairly safe but then with the the
internet coming along which in many ways
is wonderful because it actually
democratized the ability to speak to
people
but it also simultaneously turned up the
competition dial and so now these media
companies are having to compete with all
these citizen journalists
which is incentivizing them to do you
know they've still got to try and make
money so
all these the the the the the the the
incentives and rewards for being the one
who can do put out the most clickable
headline
overwhelm them and that's why we're
seeing this sea of Click bait and
frankly you know dishonesty and and
divisiveness because that's the other
thing divisiveness seems to be the most
profitable way bro your anger is the
Surefire way of getting clicks yep
um so it seems like the culture wars
maybe I don't know if the culture wars
were inevitable but they
certainly seemed to be a product of this
in
improperly designed system it was that
one designed the internet no one
designed the media industry it just kind
of evolved but if it carries on on the
current trajectory it's on it's not it's
not looking it's not boning well for
sort of Truth and unity yeah like even
the ability to make sense of reality
yeah
what do we do about something like this
the trillion dollar question
um
I don't know what the solution is to
this
but
the one practical thing we can each be
doing is basically making a commitment
to being Integrity in Integrity to
ourselves
so if we have a belief about something
we should obviously do our best to like
navigate the various biases and wants
and and and and and so on that we will
have when we get a belief but
at the very least make a commitment to
only saying what we believe to be true
yep which so many people are not even
following hmm
because it's just like well you know I
could Spin My Title this way I know you
know or if I if I write my tweet in this
way I know it's going to get more
attention
and it's not technically lying it's just
it's just a flare I'm adding to it
just making a commitment to be like no
I'm going to as best I can minimize that
and just whatever I put out there is as
close to what I personally believe to be
true that's a huge stepping stone
because then at least we're not having
we're not we're honest with ourselves
about what we think and in the people in
our immediate Network who we know we
trust if we're if you know you'll make
an agreement okay we're going to do this
with ourselves at least now there's a
small cluster of of Truth and and I
sounds pie in the sky but I just think
this will be like an emergent thing that
if enough people start doing it then
we're going to start seeing something
cool and more like grounded in reality
arise
um so that's step one
and and it's actually something
practical that we can all do
um but beyond that uh so I'll hopefully
have my uh as I said my podcast will be
out by the time this comes out and I did
an interview with Jordan Hall and we
talk a lot about this so go listen to
that because we go into it in quite a
lot of depth
um and
then perhaps we can sort of utilize some
so you know technology to help us with
this you know like blockchain seems like
it has a lot of potential right because
it's a way of recording truth you know
in an indelible way so I'm not a
blockchain expert anyway but again sort
of the systems thinkers who've spoken to
a lot say like there's there's some
value in there
um but yeah no
don't know when that's part of the
reason I'm like talking about this is
just I want smart people who were like
you know you have a lot of smart people
listening to this to just be inspired
and start thinking about it nice yeah
like yeah I can't begin to think of what
the solutions are but um we'll put links
together
honestly not really like as you as you
were describing that whole clickbait
thing I was like oh man so many video
titles where
you know I know if I'd call the video
how I ranked first at Cambridge
University it would get loads of clicks
it's not strictly true so maybe in one
exam in one year where it's like one
right joint first prize for like
technically you know spin it
um and it's those incentives at like the
sort of like dozens of times a day if
not hundreds across the population
especially in an internet enabled world
of social media where you're chasing
clicks and attention I just yeah as you
were describing that I was like oh [__]
um yeah it's like we're trapped in this
an attention game but game is the nice
way of calling it in reality it's an
attention War you know because what's a
different you know the definition of War
You could argue it's it's the ultimate
negative sum game like look at the
Russia Ukraine conflict Russia decided
to start this
it seems to me like an incredibly
needless conflict there are no winners
there are no it's just lose lose the
more it continues so that's what war is
it's it's it's it's it's the ultimate
negative sum game
and by the way the original definition
of Malik came from an old Bible story
about this cult this cult who would like
War obsessed and was so desperate to
like gain military power they would
sacrifice their children to a burning
Effigy of this thing
in order to get more military might oh
well Dark As It Gets yeah and that's and
then it's sort of like the legend of
this thing has like sort of come through
you know through the survived Through
The Years
um and it was Scott Alexander who first
put it into you know the meditations on
monologue blog into like game theoretic
terms and then I've sort of like tweaked
the definition I call it the god of
unhealthy competition but you can think
of it as the god of war and which brings
me to like so talking about solution
again no clear answer but the thing that
sort of resonates the most to me is you
know I was thinking like okay so if
that's what mollock is and let's try and
get you know in my videos I dress up as
it to try and give it a personality
because it's such a nebulous concept
like how can you make it a little bit
more memeable to people so they can
understand it uh so give it a
personality what would its personality
be like it's like this
monofocused I will win this like unable
to see what else is going on
um like capable at that non-narrow game
but just like lacking again wisdom
so it's like okay if that's more like
what's its inverse or at least what what
you know what is something better than
that you know if monikers have got to
lose lose what's the god of win-win and
so I haven't come up with a better name
and just call it win-win and win wins
Vibe so again I can only paint it as an
aesthetic but its Vibe is
it's like it's fun loving it just it
wants it wants it wants to have a good
time but it wants everyone to have a
good time it if Molex thing is about
winning the game win-win's thing is like
making sure that the game can continue
as many as many people can play as many
games as possible and it's like
aesthetic is kind of turquoise and
purple and it's a fun time but it's not
like holier than now like it likes to
get it likes to play a day oh you want
to have a heads up game all right let's
go and it will play
um you know it will it'll have a really
it will throw itself into like a sort of
zero-sum game when it you know when it's
okay to do so but it has the wisdom to
go okay that's that's enough competition
now we need to cooperate and so on so
it's like this
it's just this wise but fun loving not
austere like it like wants to have a
good time type of deity
um again sounds sounds nuts but like
this is what has been the thing that
resonates most with me personally and I
think I'm not saying that's what people
you know others should follow but like
think about what that you know this this
this
this essence of win-win competition and
collaboration looks like to you and it's
to be clear it's not opposite of molok
because that would have put it on the
same scale it's something bigger it it
can existent exist in its World it just
knows how to like slap it down that's
enough out of you yeah your little arms
race there is getting a bit much yeah
stop that
um so that's where that's where I've
gotten to in this
that yeah that really resonates with me
as well um and as you were describing
that I was thinking of like you know
playing playing board games for example
with a big fan of the board game
articulate amazing stuff
um and it can get very competitive and
you can just start like shouting people
and and all this kind of stuff I think
certainly when I was younger I was very
like hyper competitive on this thing
just like we have to win and then after
a while I was like hang on like the
point of the game is that for for all of
us to have fun right so there are
occasions in which like even though
our team could win by sort of
steamrolling the other team that's not
particularly fun for them so let's like
pull our punches just a little bit
because ultimately people have come over
to my place to hang out and have pizza
and board games let's take a job you
know that kind of thing you want the
game you want the game to cap and again
yeah you don't want it to get so intense
that you essentially break the playing
field you know piss off your friends so
much that like actually we didn't have a
good time we're not gonna play again
um yes that's exactly it and there's a
really good book as well
um that sort of encapsulate this called
uh infinite infinite and finite games
um honestly you can just read the first
two chapters and you get you get the
premise it's it's again like
molec is winning the short-term game
right in front of you whatever it takes
including sacrificing your children or
whatever
um win-win is like just keeping the game
keeping the game going
um that's that that is the ultimate game
is to keep the game going
what's your infinite game
great question
um
I I think about this in the context of
how I want to spend my time right I
think when uh earlier in my life uh like
I mean especially with like a medical
career trajectory it's very sort of
there's always like a next goal a next
thing thing to do
um it's very finite gaming of like oh I
need to try and get a first in the exams
or whatever uh and then kind of Since
since losing that identity for me I've
been thinking a lot around
what is the game I want to play purely
for the sake of playing the game
um
for like this YouTube channel and this
podcast business and stuff infinite game
is just like actually just being able to
continue to do cool interviews with cool
people
and so when it comes to the choice of
getting your ridiculously controversial
guests on the podcast is to get views
versus does that actually reduce the
risk of uh reduce the chances of being
able to continue to play this game and
enjoy it over the long term so I think
about that a lot in terms of like how do
I want to spend my own time and what are
the things I want to be working on
almost infinitely rather than finitely
I'm curious I'm curious if you think of
that at all like what that's like for
you
yeah I mean the thing that's coming up
is
just like
more new experiences right just
if I look back at my life the most
notable
I mean sometimes I'll be just doing the
same thing you know like cuddling on the
couch with Igor or whatever and just
like those moments but just having these
like what the [__] moments in life where
like you think you've got it all figured
out and they're like whoa and then
there's this just this new surprise
comes at you from Left Field I want more
of that and
because now you've got a new puzzle
Sovereign
I thought I'd discovered everything the
fog of Wars lift it no wait there's a
whole realm Beyond here and
I suspect that you know I mean I don't
know whether it's finite or infinite but
there's we haven't even begin to explore
what is actually going on in this
reality
so that's the infinite game to me
um a friend of mine
um she uh
one of our favorite sort of
things we like to play with is the item
we call it the game
um which is that we're actually in a
giant escape room and the goal is to
find the key to unlock it iterative to
find out what's really going on outside
and to solve all the puzzles nice
um and
I think that's the pattern who knows
maybe that's our purpose as you know
humans we've like we've spawned on this
particular planet
and what we've it's each of us have
subspawned in our own little spots and
but as a collective you know we are
slowly you know what's what's the
purpose of science is right it's just
understanding reality and it now seems
like because it's having more and more
you know the more people I mention like
this energy stuff too or whatever
they're more the people are like
actually I've had a little bit of
something like this too and and
so it seems like the territory has grown
a little bit and uh
you know I hope we make it off the
planet too and actually exploring the
sort of three-dimensional physical space
but it seems like there's some hyper
dimensional stuff going on as well that
yeah we can play with mental stuff yeah
have you ever heard an unexplainable
um
no not really my brother has and I'm a
lot of friends close to me have can you
share it
um yeah my brother had an experience
where
uh and and and and this was the thing
that gave him a lot of conviction about
religion
um about Islam in particular he had an
experience at University where you know
he wasn't feeling particularly great he
wasn't
um you know struggling with exams and
kind of stressed out and so he randomly
got a call from
um one of his friends who happened to be
the president of the Islamic society and
the guy just you know was asking him hey
you know how's it going and that was
completely random for him he just hadn't
their relationship wasn't the sort where
the guy would randomly ring him but the
guy said that yeah you know I just I
just had the feeling that you know I
should just like check up on you and
think and see how things were going and
they had a conversation after that
conversation my brother was like oh my
God like how how did how could he
possibly have known how did he have the
intuition it's like that doesn't make
any sense at all
um and that really helped get my brother
out of like a kind of dark spot in his
life and that gave him conviction that
like there's got to be something out
there right
um
and I'm quite kind of jealous of people
have the sorts of experiences because it
really
seems to on an emotional level help you
really know that there is something out
there that we don't quite understand
whereas I feel like right now for me I'm
still stuck in stuck in the rational
world of uh materialism and the things
that I can see in touch with the things
that exist so I'm Keen to explore like
meditation stuff the Psychedelic stuff
don't tell my mum and like all of the
other occulty type stuff uh at some
point yeah yeah and maybe I don't know
look more into the religion thing as
well yeah no it's on the it's on the
there's clearly yeah there's something
going on the fact that shamans
independently arose in almost every
indigenous tribe
who had not spoken to each other you
know ever but like diverged
millions of years well no I'm sorry
diverge the thousands tens of thousands
of years ago and yet these same things
pop up like where shamans were often
like you know this this seemingly
unnecessary part of the human experience
and that like
monotheistic religion okay that kind of
came out from sort of a similar place
but
there's clearly something to this and it
also seems somewhat absurd to me that
it seems more implausible to me that the
Universe sprung out
Randomness and nothing
then like was in was create you know
intentionally created by something yeah
and what's funny is like you know so
many of the sort of like materialist
types are now like subscribing to the
simulation argument yep that's
indistinguishable from religion actually
like it's it's you know it's the same
it's just it's just put into like modern
day terms
and that's great you know so there's
clearly like there's something that we
keep converging on yeah and
doesn't mean it
definitely true but it's worth exploring
and it and it's and it's okay
um it's okay to be agnostic essentially
um which I imagine most people I think
most people yeah it's like it's rare to
find someone who's so staunchly atheist
definitely doesn't exist but at the same
time like I do it the the like the
classical biblical definitions of this
like all loving God when you then see
all these like terrible things happening
it's like that's hard to marry up so
maybe that definition doesn't quite work
as well but maybe it's like something
created and it was like oh no no don't
no no don't do that you know like that's
possible you know it can still be caring
but like unable to do something for
example I don't know you know like a
simulator presses play on their thing
they can't then like tweak it
necessarily who knows who knows yeah so
much to explore
um thank you so much this has been
wonderful I'd love to end by asking for
a few recommendations from you so uh
we've got all these things that we're
going to put in in the video description
um and in the show notes
um and you know your latest YouTube
video which will be out by the times of
things your YouTube channel your podcast
things across
um I I have a gym session now so I'm
going to be listening to Metallica As a
bit of a Gateway right into metal um any
books that you'd recommend for me and
the audience yeah fiction non-fiction
can be anything that's that you found
Nova scene by James Lovelock
fairly nice short read nice uh
who he's amazing because he he only very
recently died like age 100 and he wrote
this when he was 98 and he was one of
the most polymathy brilliant scientist
he wasn't he was he was everything he
was like incredible scientists made so
many just go read his Wikipedia it's
incredible so he wrote that
inadequate equilibrium
which is technically an e-book by
eleazkowski
and then the next one will be and I've
haven't read it fully but I've read
parts of it and I've been very much in
like close to the writing of it it's by
one of my dearest friends Tim Urban oh
yeah and it's going to be called The
Tale of us and it should be out by the
time this comes out but if if it's not
it will be out imminently
um and it's about
understanding again this like
divisiveness and why we seem to be
everyone's so angry and like just why
tribalism is what it is and why it's
gotten so bad in particular lately
um that's going to be a really important
read uh nice yeah yeah I love Tim Urban
so I'm looking forward to checking that
out you should have him on here I'd love
to yeah yeah invest in the US isn't it
yeah he's in New York New York he's
incredible nice I will reach out to you
for an intro if that's right when I when
I absolutely New York that would be
awesome to have them yeah
um fantastic and I guess final question
is any um kind of
we we talked about how you'd recommend
people learn poker not necessarily make
a living from it because it's a lot of
valuable lessons to be learned there
anything else in terms of sort of
experiences and new things to try out
that you would recommend for people like
I'm fishing for recommendations for
myself here like I want to you know this
like
any activities any sports any any things
that you've done where you think oh more
people should try this thing and I
didn't really know that this was the
thing until I tried it out
uh well yeah
um bouldering climbing specifically
yeah we evolved to be great climbers
human beings our bodies are actually
very very naturally good for us good
good at it
and even though there's a really steep
learning curve like you'll have forearm
tightness and like you'll feel like I'll
never be able to do this stick at it for
a couple of months because your grip
strength will come remarkably quickly
and what I love about it so much is it's
kind of like physical chess
in that it's not just a pure it's not
just like hammering out weights in the
gym or it's just like pure Brawn or like
who can run the fastest it's it's
you have to like think through your body
and learn what your body what you know
how it moves and it's so Dynamic and
it's and particularly in bouldering like
there'll be different problems that are
set and they're literally called
bouldering problems so it's like a
puzzle to solve that happens to be
physical yeah so for people who like a
bit of intellectual stimulation in their
exercise it's the best
um and particularly if you find a
partner who you can go with who's like
roughly a similar level then you can
like challenge each other a little bit
and it's you'll also learn together it's
just it's it's been my obsession now for
the last couple of years and it's so
good it's so fun it destroys your hands
my hands are a mess but it's worth it
nice yeah we've got a building wall uh
next door oh well fairly close here
close by to here which I haven't haven't
checked out yet so that's that's
inspired me to give it a go yeah yeah
well if thank you so much thank you
we'll put links to all of your stuff
down in the video description in the
show notes wherever people are watching
listening to this any final asks or
recommendations for the audience
ideas on how to solve the molok problem
and make more win-wins please uh contact
me
um yeah amazing thank you so much it's
been wonderful thank you all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye